well
two
let's just go
all right so I think we're gonna get
started
um
do an introduction and I'll hand you the
microphone oh okay
cool and this is the one that's actually
going to go out so oh okay awesome well
hi everyone thanks for coming out today
um we're excited to have this joint
event with with Chicago our user group
my name is Olivia I'm from PI data
Chicago and then this is sochang our
co-organizer and then Justin from
Chicago our user group
um and we would just like to thank our
major sponsor numb Focus numb focus is a
non-profit organization that supports
and promotes development and Adoption of
Open Source scientific software many
well-known python libraries are
supported and maintained by num focus it
provides funding and Community Support
to software including but not limited to
Jupiter pandas matplotlib numpy sci-fi
Julia and dask in turn dumb focus is
supported by several large companies
including IBM Microsoft and Intel
um yeah and we are recording this talk
so anyone who wants to share it in the
future you can do that
um yeah and then I'm really pleased to
introduce Brian Peterson
and I'll just read a quick intro about
you
um so Brian is a Quant an educator and
an entrepreneur and an open source
advocate he is on The Graduate faculty
of financial engineering at the
University of Illinois where he teaches
about the design and Analysis of
automated trading systems Brian is also
an entrepreneur who manages multiple
firms mostly but not exclusively in the
financial services Arena where he works
as a quantitative analyst
Brian is also the author and co-author
of more than 10 top stories packages for
using RN Finance the longtime
co-administrator for art and languages
participation in the annual Google
summer of code and open source program
and a founder and member of the
committee for the annual art Finance
open source Finance conference
held at UIC in Chicago okay so I'll get
hand it over to Justin if you want to
say anything about Chicago
hello everybody thanks for coming my
name is Justin Shay I help organize a
Chicago our user group I'm also a
faculty member here at Roosevelt
University Hensler space where I direct
the finance honors track where I teach
students how to use R I hope to include
some python in the future here but for
now it's just hard to do our statistical
analysis and back testing
um and so uh as as Olivia mentioned uh
we've got our R and finance conference
coming up May 19th and 20th that's at
UIC uh and so I think we've got about 30
35 talks
um some of them are even python some of
them are python
for example uh other uh Pi data
organizer lead organizer here is going
to be speaking there
um and so if you kind of like the
material that's being presented today
it'll be this sort of level of figure
for many of the talks
um although this is once probably more
in the upper tier of of the rigor uh but
anyways
um thank you all for coming and I'm
going to turn it over to Brian now
well thank you all for having me
um
so I want to say a little bit first
about uh
how this topic uh actually first I'll
say
um I write both Python and R and several
other languages as well
um we tend to use R for statistical
analysis and that shouldn't be
surprising to anyone because R was
originally created as an S like language
and S was the language that was created
for statistics at at T Bell Labs so I
write python code every single day but
usually just for gluing other stuff
together I use it for moving data around
I use it for transforming data I
occasionally use it for certain machine
learning models but generally speaking
when I need to do statistics I use a
language that was designed from the
ground up for doing statistics so one of
the things we'll see here is I'll
reference python packages and python
ways of doing things where I can in this
talk but uh
because design of experiments is a field
of Statistics you shouldn't be surprised
that there's far more design of
experiments in a statistics language
than there is in Python so again I use
Python every day but when we're doing
statistics we usually use R
um so
I'll say something else uh I started
working on this particular topic maybe
as much as a decade ago where I started
thinking about design of experiments and
how it would fit into what I do every
day which is quantitative Finance
um
I didn't get very far though because
there's basically you could count on one
hand the number of papers that
rigorously use design of experiments in
finance there's almost nothing out there
and none of them are good they're all
they're all horrible in fact we
replicated them they didn't work they
had bad methodologies and it just wasn't
useful to us so last summer
um I took uh I took my family on
vacation I came home with the one uh
souvenir I didn't want I came home with
covet uh and got brain fog for a few
days I'm vaccinated my family's
vaccinated I was never I never felt I
was in danger but I simply couldn't
think for four or five days and I
realized and I realized I was doing
better when I wanted to do math again
and write code again and I realized that
I didn't have to be back in the office
for about a week and so this is very
rare for me to have a week when nobody
is going to bother me and when I can
actually think hard thoughts so the
Genesis of most of this work was in a
week last summer when I could actually
synthesize a bunch of stuff I've been
thinking about for a very long time and
put it start putting it all together and
applying it specifically to quantitative
Finance so the examples that we're going
to talk about in this talk are from
quantitative Finance
um
now come on only if it lets me change
slides
yeah that should work but it's not
I tried that too
that's why it signed me out
there we go
that works okay
so
whoops
why did we hit that
it is a Mac that's the problem
all right
control and we're sharing screen yeah I
am sharing so okay sorry about that so
it had logged me out between when I was
teaching and when I came up here so
um so anyway so so design of experiments
was a field that was started over 100
years ago uh by statistician uh R.A
Fisher so you you've heard his name in
kind of any statistics tests you find
his statistics all over the place uh
design experiments is widely applied in
fields like agriculture psychology
studies pharmaceutical research
manufacturing chemical engineering as I
said earlier it's not widely applied in
quantitative Finance where I spend most
of my time
um so for those of you uh who are in
some of those other fields you can find
tons and tons of research on design of
experiments and I strongly recommend
that you go look for some of this
research because it'll save you a ton of
effort especially computational effort
so for today's talk we're going to focus
mostly on uh computation and on how this
fits into
um computational experiments as opposed
to physical experiments if we have time
at the end I'll talk more about some of
the areas of design experiments that
apply to physical experiments but many
of these many of the things that were
designed 100 years ago not surprisingly
for physical experiments don't apply as
much in computational experiments and
since we're here at a data science uh
Meetup I assume that lots of you are
dealing with computational experiments
rather than physical experiments
so one of the problems of approaching
design of experiments
um is that uh
that it's really filled with kind of
difficult terminology
I'm sorry Justin I didn't think that I
should use a white background in a dark
a dark uh dark text
um so
so you know there's often the words
themselves in design of experiments
aren't difficult at all but uh they're
drawn from the fields of research where
they were originally employed so we have
things like plots coming out of
Agriculture or treatment plans from uh
from medical from medical research we
have contrasts from biological sciences
now I'm a scientist originally so I get
all this stuff but it's very hard it was
very hard for me to approach design of
experiments uh because it became very
difficult to kind of think about how
these things come together so what I'm
going to try to do today is I'm going to
try to present these techniques using
terminology that may be more common to
you from data science
um and and quantitative descriptions
rather than necessarily focusing on uh
the design of experiments
descriptions
so why are we doing all this
um we're trying to evaluate the cause
and effect of our changes on our inputs
methodically test our parameters to
evaluate parameter dependencies and
overcome noise and our goal is to
overcome biases that assume that data is
randomized or independent or normally
distributed so in many cases many
branches of Statistics assume
independent uh independent observations
they assume normality uh I can't assume
any of those things in my world in my
world it's almost never true my data
isn't stationary I have fat tail data I
have random data I have jumps in my data
this is one of the reasons why design of
experiments is really important because
it enforces normalization of the
parameter research space and it allows
us to more readily examine those IID
assumptions or overcome them based on
using better experiment designs it
allows us to make better predictions of
the effects of our parameter changes and
perhaps most importantly in a world
where we often have you know thousands
of features uh and you know billions of
rows of data it allows us to use less
compute to find meaningful answers one
of the biggest problems that we find in
large computational studies is things
like multiple testing bias overfitting
biases so we can use smaller sets of
tests to actually get more statistically
meaningful results so we use both less
compute and get answers faster and we
have less chance of what we're fitting
our data so that should be interesting
to anybody who's ever dealt with really
large data sets and thrown a whole bunch
of stuff against the wall
so why wouldn't we just test everything
um there's often too many combinations
tens of thousands to Millions to
billions of possible combinations to
test it's too expensive to test in
compute in time and money and wasted
output
um in any non-smooth or non-linear
interaction multiple testing bias is a
huge problem
um
there are lots of statistical models
that are used to adjust for multiple
testing bias and you can often find that
if you
apply a giant test where you test
millions of possibilities or billions of
possibilities what you can find is that
you may have
no statistical power at all left at that
point so even if your results might be
valid they statistically might be
completely invalid
so if you start using things like fixed
level designs in uh design experiments
which we'll talk about in a bit the
power and precision of the of your test
is actually increased by the product of
the levels so you can do a smaller
number of tests and get a more
statistically significant test
so the too long don't read about this is
the more parsimonious tests can actually
have significantly higher power
so why not test things one at a time
lots of classical approaches to
parameter experiments vary one variable
at a time
um there's two big problems with that
one it's inefficient and two it can't
account for parameter interactions now
at least in my world uh there are almost
always parameter interactions and so we
want to really account for those
um additionally it assumes that you hold
constant or fixed all the other
parameters so none of the other
parameters vary so that's why testing
one at a time generally doesn't work
so let's start with the idea of a Brute
Force approach or what's called a full
factorial approach so in this in this
type of model all combinations are
tested so in um in R you do this with
the with the expand grid function
um and we get we're going to use two
examples here that we'll come back to in
a little bit to explain why we might
want to use fewer tests uh so we're
going to do a three five things taken
three at a time where each parameter has
three levels and five things taken five
at a time uh where each has where each
parameter has five levels uh in Python
you do this with list comprehensions
um where you kind of do you know the
range for each one keep going there the
list comprehensions get really
complicated so I don't like doing it
that way but you can do that relatively
easily in Python
um so so at the end of that what you end
up with is you end up with these these
giant lists these giant tables of
combinations for your Brute Force
combination so your three-way design has
243 rows your five-way design has three
thousand rows
um so that's the total number of Brute
Force combinations here now if you look
at this uh in the columns here variable
one two three four five you just you
just literally are building every
combination one two three four five in
variable one and all ones and everything
else and then one two three four five in
variable one and all twos in the second
variable and so on and so forth so
you're actually getting all of the
possible combinatorial combinations of
these parameters
um now this is a relatively tiny example
this is a very small toy
and and so uh so you realize that we're
already at 3 000 combinations on this
very small toy
so we're going to try a small example um
it's a Bollinger band example for those
of you who aren't in finance it doesn't
really matter what it does it's a
trading strategy that's often used to
describe uh mean reverting or trending
trending models but the key thing for
this purpose is that it has two
parameters
um it has a standard deviation which are
the bands in a range of one to three and
it has a moving average which is the
midpoint in a range of 10 to 40. so with
a step size of one that creates 93
parameter combinations not very many
parameter combinations at all and
there's no reason not to brute force
that small of a set but for our example
we'll use that to just kind of think
about this so if we do a regression
model we can look at the importance of
each of those parameters and if you look
at little stars uh in here in this table
you'll see that
um not only both of the parameters are
significant in terms of their
predictions but also the combinations of
the parameters are significant uh the
the ma parameter and the standard
deviation parameter the combinations of
these are also are significant so what
we're doing here is we're analyzing the
parameter interaction and finding that
the interaction of the two is also
significant
so in regression terms in direct
regression terms uh direct regression
effects are typically denoted with an
additive model so y with respect to a
plus b
um interaction effects are denoted with
a multiplicative model so y with respect
to a times B the parameter importance
regression demonstrated the parameters
are all significant both individually
and in combination but how do we
understand those interactions we can
examine those interactions too as as
things vary so
um in this case what we're doing is
we're looking at all the parameter
interactions uh what you're seeing here
on the x-axis is the moving average
parameter the rows are the lines are
each of the standard deviation
parameters those only varied from one to
three so we have three lines here and
then the uh the left hand column the
y-axis is different objective functions
that again come out of Finance net
trading p l profit Factor number of
Trades average win loss ratio which
again art is important for this if
you're not in finance but what we see
here is pretty interesting in that on
the top row we see that the lines cross
each other a lot so that's a visual way
of seeing that the parameters are
actually interacting with each other so
if the lines never cross the parameters
aren't interacting so you can see just
visually that these parameters have
interactions so even though we already
knew that from the regression analysis
that we did we can see it visually here
as well
um except for the one on the bottom
where we see that against number of
Trades they're clearly significant in
that there's a clear pattern as the
moving average parameter goes up the
number of Trades goes down which makes
sense because that a moving average
parameter is a longer look back period
so there are fewer trades and as the
number of standard deviations goes up
there are fewer trades the top line is
the smallest number of standard
deviations so it's the tightest the
tightest range of variation and the
bottom line is the largest standard
deviation so it's got the smallest
number of Trades but those parameters
aren't interacting in that sense so
they're clearly significant because you
can see the pattern but they are also
not interacting in that case and in the
final case the average win loss ratio it
doesn't look like they're even
significant you know there's not a clear
pattern it's not sloping up into the
right or down into the left and but
there's clearly some some noise
interaction in there so we can see
things very quickly by modeling this
regression interaction even though that
regression interaction isn't important
to what we're trying to find out at the
end
you
so you can also build plots of these
These are called response surface plots
uh you can do it with any plotting
package you can use two parameters and a
response variable you can use a
parameter and two response variables you
can use a composite coded parameter
interaction
um they make very pretty 3D plots we
find them completely useless so we
sometimes put them in presentations
because they look nice but I don't find
them useful in terms of actually doing
any sort of real analysis
but there's a bunch of statistical
analysis that you can do with response
Services as well but they're really all
regression problems so they're all
looking at regression coefficients
um so you can get standard regression
models to evaluate these interactions I
showed you one a little bit earlier you
can get some additional tools if we use
standard coding we'll talk about that in
a little bit
software packages like RSM and R uh SAS
has multiple response surface functions
functions there's a little bit in the pi
doe package in Python for doing response
surfaces
um but but really uh what's most people
are trying to do when they do response
surface analysis is they're trying to do
optimization they're trying to actually
predict the response based on the
changes in individual variables
foreign so getting into design of
experiments itself what let's say we've
got hundreds of thousands or millions of
parameters and we'll show a bigger
example in a little bit we want to we
want to test fewer things because it's
just too expensive to test hundreds of
thousands of things and maybe learn
nothing and maybe have low statistical
power so what we'd really like to do is
we'd like to do something called the
screening design our goal is to evaluate
our parameter importance to determine
interactions between those critical
parameters if you think things are
linear you can do uh relatively smart
relatively tiny numbers of parameters
you can have a high and a low value for
each parameter if you think the
combinations are linear so now you get
two to the K combinations where K is the
number of parameters
um if the parameters or convex are
quadratic you might move to three or
five levels for each parameter now you
have n to the K combination where n is
the number of levels and K is the number
n is the number of
K is the number parameters and N is the
number of levels so uh in these cases
what you're doing is you're vastly
decreasing your total search space in
order to get a reasonable coverage of
the whole Space without having to test
everything all at once
so ideally the whole point of doing this
kind of design of experiments approach
is that we want to use the most
parsimonious design we can to run our
experiments we want to preserve degrees
of freedom for those of you who are used
to regression analysis you can think in
degree of Freedom terms how many degrees
of freedom are consumed by the analysis
if you run a million combinations of all
the things you've used all your degrees
of freedom so the likelihood that you
have a statistically valid result is
very very low so by shrinking the number
of tests that we run we actually
increase our statistical likelihood that
we haven't overfit and that we still
have degrees of freedom
um hopefully it increases Insight it
becomes easier to explain and understand
a smaller model than it is to understand
the whole model but there are a lot of
butts in this process we need to be
cognizant of random or uncontrollable
effects and we need to be cognizant of
where we might have uh less smooth
parameter interactions where we need to
do things a little bit more completely
so let's assume again that even in this
kind of screening design level we have
still have way too many things there are
way too many combinations for us to work
with we have too many parameters we have
too many levels so we can start thinking
about
um reducing the number of Levels by
reducing the the size the number of
levels and uh or reducing the number of
parameters k
um we can still run into millions of
Trials so what we want to start thinking
about is how we can parameterize those
those things and when we run into
constraints we run into other
statistical issues
so one of the common approaches to this
is coding where we code things down to
zero to one or negative one zero one uh
which can kind of numerically code for
we can numerically code for categorical
variables so if you've got variables
that have you know text values you can
use numerical coding for those one of
the problems with that is that you're
depending on how you're doing
optimization or how you're doing the
analysis your Optimizer may assume that
those categorical variables are evenly
distributed or are sorted in a
particular order which could be
absolutely wrong I mean I don't know why
a comes before Z except that a comes
before Z so there's no real reason why
categorically coding those into numbers
makes sense
um so you can transform the parameter
space into some easier way to think
about this some software methodologies
require that kind of approach but again
you need to take some care that you're
not actually making things worse rather
than better by doing those kinds of
things
um always you should think about
reducing the number of parameters one of
the biggest problems in machine learning
research we use a lot of machine
learning models a lot of machine
learning papers come out of things like
image analysis or text analysis where
you have relatively stationary data
that's relatively similar self-similar
pictures of cats or pictures of cats
right I can change the color I can
change the I can change the breed it's
still a picture of a cat this is what we
call stationary data
um if your data isn't those things then
then you're going to have problems with
hundreds or thousands of parameters so
um
but but normally what you can think
about is which parameters are the most
important so you can do things like
studies on parameter importance to try
to get at ideas of how to get these
things to figure these things out
so
what you find is the if you do small
screening designs you can find that
there if there are a large number of
parameters up front you need something
adjustment
yeah
that's their mission Pizza intermission
all right
so um
so anyway so so what we find is that uh
most experiments with large number of
parameters have only a few parameters
that are that have a large effect on the
outcome
I think we're going to be fine okay uh
our director main effects are are more
likely to be important than parameter
interactions we'll see this when we get
to a larger example in just a minute
um this is something that's known as the
hierarchical ordering principle so it's
been known for a long time that if
you've got hundreds of parameters or
thousands of parameters only a small
number of them are actually likely to be
significant and only a small number of
interactions are like these
so there are of course models where
there are very small effects and you're
trying to pick those up but most models
in the real world especially on
non-stationary data have a small number
of parameters that actually matter
um there are approaches to do
hierarchical experiment design uh
Bayesian designs come into this in many
cases they are definitely useful in some
places they're not terribly useful in my
field of Finance
um if the number of parameters or
interactions is really large it can also
be a reason to do hierarchical designs
but uh if it's widely used in your field
there are certainly processes for
handling these
so we've thought about all this we've
taken out as many parameters as we can
we've reduced our number of levels we
still have too many combinations so what
can we do well we can sharply constrain
the number of levels and parameters even
more than we already had we can add more
constraints or we can get into what are
called fractional factorial designs
um so this includes things like random
sampling uh Latin hypercube designs are
one way of doing random samples uh you
can use random design points within a
range for many years I used uniform
random samples which can cover the area
very well but don't have a lot of
statistical power so if you want to
Simply cover the space you can use a
uniform random sample but you may not
have good statistical power because you
may have missed turning points or
inflection points in your data
um Bayesian sampling is widely used uh
when you have hierarchical models and
fedorov uh designs there it is in
Cyrillic for those of you who speak
Russian I don't
um one of the problems with this is is
actually that you'll find it's spelled
about four different ways in English so
uh in English he saw he spells it
fedorov but most of the most of the
software implementations that I know of
spell it federerov with an ER instead of
an or so
um but these designs we'll talk about
more in a bit because they're important
so all fractional factorial designs the
random designs are easy but they have
low statistical power they may not have
good coverage of the space they do have
the advantage of incorporating complex
constraints which is why I started using
them many years ago
variants such as the Latin hypercube
seek to improve that coverage most of
the reference designs for Latin
hypercubes are in Python they seek to
find at least one uh Center random Point
inside each inflection set so they're a
way of kind of getting good coverage
without covering the entire space
um
they uh you can omit certain parameter
combinations or ranges that might miss
effects which are more important
um but uh hierarchical Bayesian models
are very powerful but they typically use
multiple rounds of designs so any design
which takes the full Brute Force which
is called the full factorial design and
shrinks it down is called a fractional
factorial
now
when I in the types of models that I
deal with we tend to use algorithmic
fractional factorial designs the most
powerful method here uh is the fedorov
designs uh so a full factorial test
covers all combinations there are
algorithms designed specifically for
computational experiments so thus useful
to this group of people
um that still maximize our coverage so
mathematically this is known as what's
de-optimal design because you are trying
to maximize the variance covariance
coverage of the determinant of the
multi-dimensional Matrix I decided not
to put three or four slides of math up
here to explain why that all works but
uh but it seems to all work people have
been studying this for about 30 years
and they seem to work really well the
federal algorithm maximizes that
coverage by calculating support points
in the multi in the multivariate
ellipsoid space so the the math again is
pretty complicated but uh it it works
pretty well if you have constraints
there's Monte Carlo versions of the
federal design that can get very close
like 98 to 99
d-optimal designs where there are still
many parameters or very complex
constraints so for example you've got
this space and you cut off a whole
corner of it well now it's very hard to
use traditional design models to cut off
that corner that's why people often
results resort to randomization
so uh let's take our original Three
level and five level examples
um where we had originally 243 and 3125
uh rows and let's take an
algorithmically uh an algorithmic
fractional federov design here so if we
apply the
um fedorov design to this where we're
using quadratic constraints
um and we're approximating uh to get to
the final answer so that the code runs
faster you can go from 243 rows in The
Brute Force to 202 rows in The Brute
Force for the three level design not a
big deal you didn't get a whole lot of
benefit there but in the five level
design you know five things taken five
at five levels for each one we go from
three thousand levels to two to two
hundred and thirty
um and we still have over 99 statistical
coverage of the whole Space so you can
see how you gained a significant amount
of benefit by using a smaller design
without having to go further than that
so let's quickly run through a larger
example
um
so we've used two small examples to
illustrate we use the small example of
the Bollinger Bands to illustrate
parameter reactions and we use the small
examples of the three-way and five-way
to demonstrate how an algorithmic design
could decrease our search space
um design of experiments really is most
useful in the total search space is huge
or expensive
so in physical experiments things are
expensive because you can't change the
machines that easily or because it's
really expensive to make mistakes on a
production line or because you only have
so many patients in a in a in an actual
live study in Psychology or in medical
research
um or in computational experiments which
I think this room and and the people
watching online are more likely to be uh
you have just so many possible
combinations that it's expensive in
terms of compute it can cost thousands
or even tens of thousands of dollars to
run tests on on a cloud
um and and maybe your your boss says
that that's too much money so you want
to do it in a faster period of time or
you don't want to break your laptop uh
melting your laptop is a very real
possibility
so let's examine an example that better
approximates a real problem it's still a
toy example but it's a large toy
so we talked about a Bollinger band
strategy which is abandoned midpoint
strategy it's very common in
quantitative Finance uh real strategies
of this type tend to be significantly
more complex uh than the one we examined
earlier so in this case we're going to
go from using one asset to using nine
assets still not very many
um and we're going to uh also add some
more parameters so we add two indicators
we add we configure it uh as an up and
down Trend uh with a breakout none of
that's super important we have four
rules for those of you who aren't in
finance
but at the end of the day we have five
parameters and three constraints
so we've constrained these over
relatively small ranges so we've already
smoothed things down we've got
constraints in here with default
parameters on a single core this runs in
under 30 seconds so not super fast not
super slow
um it consumes 80 degrees of freedom and
retains over 99.8 percent of our total
degrees of freedom
now if we do a broader range of these
parameters
so we have our four parameters up top we
have the ranges here
um so we have five parameters total with
two set to be equal uh we have four
primary signals and two composite
triggering signals we have four rules
four parameter distributions plus one
equality constraint and three additional
parameter constraints
we now end up with over a hundred
thousand combinations still in a toy
right this is a toy example this is
smaller than anything that you would do
for real
if we increment all the parameter ranges
except the standard deviation which only
ranges from one to three by two rather
than incrementing by one we're now down
to twenty thousand parameters so a lot
but that doesn't sound like a lot right
we're in data science right twenty
thousand parameters doesn't sound like a
lot but we'll proceed with this smaller
example anyway
to do this as a Brute Force example on a
six core 12 thread 64 gigabyte machine
this example will run out of RAM
it'll crash it can't it can't complete
um on a relatively typical eight core 16
thread 128 gigabyte of ram workstation
the twenty thousand parameters set Brute
Force takes about 20 hours running on
all cores at a hundred percent
on a 24 core 48 thread 250 seconds
gigabyte RAM server uh which by the way
would cost you about 150 a day on Amazon
um roughly
uh The Brute Force parameter search
takes about six hours
so this is still a toy
um
real strategies with more parameters
more assets more rules higher frequency
data or all of those would obviously
take much longer to analyze for real
so what are what's our impact on degrees
of freedom are we overfitting
so if we look at the uh if we look at
this we have 52 000 Market observations
over about 20 years of data we use up 19
000 of those consumed by the strategy
our total degrees of freedom remaining
is 32 000 so we've used up 62 percent of
we have we have 62 of our degrees of
freedom remaining ideally you'd like to
have 95 or more of our degrees of
freedom remaining and in a regression
analysis so we've we've have a very high
chance here of overfitting
um and we've generously only considered
one degree of freedom for each parameter
test if we use the most conservative
counting we'd end up with negative
degrees of freedom so we have a high
chance statistically of overfitting by
using the Brute Force example
so not only is it expensive to do this
test it's also likely to give us junk
results
so let's go back to a fractional
factorial design would this help
so an unconstrained fedorov design
returns about 900 parameter sets so from
20 000 down to 900
that's a 95 reduction uh
from our full factorial example it's a
99 reduction from the original increment
by one design when we apply constraints
to the federal design there are 80
parameter sets remaining which satisfy
the constraints so we've gone from 20
000 to 900 to 80 once we constrain it
this is a 99.9 reduction from our
original set it's a 99.5 percent
reduction from the tested set it's a 92
percent reduction from the full Federal
design set
and our remaining degrees of freedom is
99.51 degrees of freedom remaining
so we have a much higher chance of a
statistically valid result and we've
taken multiple orders of magnitude off
of the computational complexity of
testing this example
um I'm going to come back to the
parameter importance regression here uh
you know so again this is a linear model
this is one line of code in R it's a
little more complicated to linear models
in Python although we do do them from
time to time where we don't want to
switch from one language to another uh
and we see that what we're doing is both
you can see the additive linear model
and fast plus and slow plus n Sig plus n
slow plus ND SD
um and we see also uh
the interaction models with the with the
uh the asterisks between the the effects
um so
uh we use the same kind of uh net
trading p l and profit to Max draw as
objectives those aren't important for
the purpose of understanding what we're
doing here when we look at the
regressions here what we see is
interesting in that all the Direct
effects are significant all the upper
ones have uh have significance or almost
all the upper ones have significance the
interactions are very are far less
likely to be significant so this is what
I was talking about earlier when I
talked about higher ordering principles
as the number of parameters goes up the
likelihood that the interactions between
the parameters are also significant goes
down
so
with so this was the the regression that
we just run ran was run on that 80
parameter sets it was run on the the
fractional federog so we were able to
get statistically significant results
from a regression model to look at how
important our original parameters were
uh based on this 80 a test of 80 of
these parameter combinations rather than
a test of 20 000 parameter combinations
or a hundred thousand parameter
combinations
um instead of 20 hours on a fast
multi-core server and relatively High
chances of what we're fitting you know a
much more parsimonious design run it
runs in about six minutes on a
Workstation
with a few chords so that's a very
reasonable time for you to think about
you know did I do this right and can I
learn anything from my model
um you know we certainly run models that
run for days
uh I'd rather not
um
I have some additional topics here I'm
going to kind of go quickly through them
uh but I know we're a little tight on
time from what Justin was saying
um
most texts on design experiments send
spend a lot of time on randomization and
replication methodologies if you are
doing physical experiments randomization
and replication help control for other
factors that you haven't otherwise
considered so they're really important
in the real world they're not really
important in computational studies in
most computational studies randomization
and replication aren't necessary
there are a few exceptions to that but
for the most part uh replication might
be useful if the model contains a
stochastic or probabilistic or other
random component
because you need to make sure that it
converges based on a whole variety of
random or conditional calculations but
other than that you shouldn't need to
think about randomization for
computational experiments
um split plot designs came out of
Agriculture because you know in a Big
Field you don't necessarily know how
much water is going to fall on each edge
of the field or different elevations on
different parts of the field so you
split it up into what are called split
plots and try things in multiple
different areas in the field again very
important in terms of physical
experiments so if you're doing physical
experiments you probably need to think
about these things generally not
important in uh in computational
experiment all the conditions in your
computational experiments are the same
um so it shouldn't matter that much
uh also though you need to remember that
if you're doing analysis of variance
Anova statistics you have to modify
those for these sorts of split plot
designs so that standard statistical
analysis for Anova doesn't work for
split plot designs unless you modify it
um split plot designs however could be
used for testing in production so once
you get beyond your computational test
and you want to actually move into real
testing you may want to start thinking
about this kind of design block designs
are are used to minimize average or
nuisance factors when you've got
variables with different inherent
properties they're likely to affect the
results when when they when you have uh
noise factors that interact with each
other you do these block designs
um
block designs make good sense in finance
for things like asset classes uh Bond
stocks FX crypto all have different
properties so you may do you may add
blocks to a computational design it
doesn't make the design any more
expensive to do it just it's a different
way of analyzing your results when it
comes out the back
um if all parameter combinations are
tested on all blocks you can use it to
assess properties on a block by block
basis or you can do block designs where
you make sure that you have uh
standardized coverage across the blocks
again far more important in physical
designs than in computational designs
but it can still be useful in
computational designs if you've got
other factors that you'd like answers
for but where you aren't going to vary
them as parameters
uh iterative sequencing of experiments
um
if you've got a really big problem
most of my problems are really big
problems which is why I've spent so many
years thinking about this and now so
much time over the last nine months
actually writing code to do this
um it may make sense to iteratively
sequence a set of experiments do small
screen experiments then do response
surface experiments then do parameter
optimization across like larger numbers
of levels for key parameters once you
know which parameters are the most
important and then get into robust
parameter designs
um we'll talk about those in just a
second but the goal here would be to
gain Insight from each stage correct
your problems earlier on and spend less
time making mistakes
so uh
if you're interested in noise or random
or things that can cause problems and
experiments uh taguchi is here he's in
the references you can look him up later
but he identified different sets of
noise
um
that a lot of this comes out of the
quality control literature uh but it
gets into what's called robust parameter
design where what we're trying to do is
we're trying to identify parameters that
minimize the overall impacts of as many
noise factors as possible uh vary those
factors that are controlled at design
time
um so the goal here is to try to have
the most stable and robust parameters
that you can so out of sample in finance
what I care about is my parameters
changing as little as possible because
if they change less I'm less likely to
overfit them
and you want to know when you need to
change them because the environment has
changed
so I often get asked about experiment
designs for feature engineering if
you're trying to design an experiment to
do feature engineering on a large
machine learning model most of the focus
of design of experiments is on whole
system outcomes so it's about thinking
about things that are already live
production processes and thinking about
how do I change things how do I change
my parameters to get better outcomes in
production designed experiments can also
be applied they're usually applied late
in the overall process well you already
have a process and now you want to
improve your parameter optimization it's
possible to use these techniques earlier
at the feature engineering stage what
you're generally changing is the target
variables if you're doing this on a
production process your objectives are
going to be production objectives you
know in my world in finance it's usually
things like profit and loss
um but when you do it in a feature
engineering world you're usually talking
about things like goodness of fit or
periodicity and persistence in the
measured feature and prediction accuracy
so you can use these techniques on
feature engineering as well anytime your
feature has multiple parameters you
should be thinking about a designed
experiment approach
um
multi-objective optimization is a is a
whole field unto itself but many real
problems have many objectives choosing
the most robust out of sample parameters
also requires taking these multiple
objectives into account one of the
biggest challenges with many machine
learning models is they tend to be
single objective models so they tend to
just look at things like gradient
descent for example as their main
objective so uh multi-objective
optimization can be an additive thing to
this type of thing where we uh start
looking at whoops where we start looking
combining or waiting the objectives
start improving our desirability
functions start treating objectives as
hidden variables or really using true
multi-objective Global solvers
um like nsga 3.
okay Justin told me to go fast so I went
fast I apologize
um
so
uh by the way these slides are all
compiled the examples that I showed you
were all compiled into the code so there
is code behind all of these things we
can make the code available if anybody
wants it send me an email I'm happy to
give you the code for all the examples
um
but what I want you to take away from
this design experiments can lower the
size of your parameter space to be
tested three or more orders of magnitude
taking you know taking a problem from
Simply computationally and feasible or
computationally very expensive something
you can do on an average sized
workstation it may still run out of RAM
on a laptop because Ram is still a
constraint but uh generally speaking
computationally you can handle it
the other really important point I think
here is that proper design can result in
more insight from your experiment more
inferential power
boiling the ocean can easily lead to
overfitting it risks
well testing bias you can give up all of
your degrees of freedom um without uh
without paying attention to these things
the other thing is that rather than
incrementally optimizing parameters as
many people do you can simultaneously
optimize all of your parameters in
relatively small tests
um
it also provides a framework for
iteratively more complex experiment
designs
and finally I think design of
experiments just a tool that should be
in every analyst's toolbox it's more
accessible than it seems in many ways
um and if you take away nothing else
think about the fact of using federov
designs for algorithmically decreasing
the number of possible parameter
combinations
some resources I highly recommend the
excellent design and Analysis of
experiments by John Lawson
um uh the dean boss and dragulic book is
also good for its breadth and it has
both SAS and our implementations uh
python is actually harder there are no
single texts that I am aware of there is
no book about design of experiments in
Python that I'm aware of the two best
packages that I know are Pi doe and and
pymo doe they're in the references at
the end when we post the slides the
online book process Improvement using
data by Kevin Dunn does contain a
chapter on design experiments in Python
I think he uses piboe for most of his
examples
um the owl design package in R contains
the algorithmic federal of fractional
factorial design that I used in this
presentation and then the classic text
on this by George box uh and Hunter
senior and Hunter Jr is statistics for
experimenters
um it's the best classic text he the
first edition of that book came out in
about 1980
um it also includes really useful
introductions to the core statistics so
I'm not a statistician I was originally
a physicist
um learning some of the statistics is
actually incredibly useful box is
probably the best of the examples for
that
and at the end of this there are a whole
bunch of references
um I think we have a few minutes before
uh the alarms are going to go off and
we're going to be ended by that
I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you very much
yeah so as as Brian just alluded to
um in lessons in why you're nice to
security guards and other support staff
at a facility like this is because they
inform me that we're about to have a
fire alarm
so uh excellent for students studying
for their finals right now they decided
to just do it now so uh that's going to
be at about seven o'clock here and
what's going to happen is they're going
to shut the elevators off and they'll
take the stairs like you know real fire
alarm Styles uh no you can't they won't
come and like clear all of this so I
suggest uh we kind of get a move on if
here or I've I have walked the 12
flights a few times and it's not great
um now I will say that